[Musica]
si stava meglio prima quante volte lo
avete sentito dire io tantissime e come
chi cerca di correre guardando indietro
e quando sento vecchie generazioni ma
anche tanti miei coetanei lamentarsi
dell'attuale innovazione in cui siamo
immersi
io gli rispondo che quella non è
innovazione l'innovazione porta
miglioramento per noi e per i nostri
paesi internet è un'innovazione pazzesca
ma se ben utilizzata se non è
involuzione uno studio realizzato da
microsoft nel 2015 ha dimostrato come la
nostra capacità di attenzione davanti a
digital device è inferiore a quella di
un pesce rosso 15 anni fa non era così
ma batte proprio il pesce rosso di un
solo secondo
negli ultimi due secoli abbiamo avuto
tre grandi rivoluzioni tre grandi
rivoluzioni che hanno portato tre grandi
crescita globali
oggi di innovazione corre la capacità di
messa a terra di una tecnologia e oggi
di poche ore
oggi ci vuole meno tempo per sviluppare
in meno tempo per raggiungere massa
critica del 3 rivoluzione che ho citato
prima si sono innescate ogni 50 60 anni
siamo nel 2019 quindi sono passati 50
anni stiamo mantenendo lo stesso ritmo
ma questo non è concepibile oggi
l'innovazione corre e quindi impediamo
un meno tempo per raggiungere il 51 per
cento della popolazione mondiale in
passato per diffondere il telefono abbia
impiegato 75 anni la radio 35 la tv 15
15 anni internet quattro anni facebook
per diffondersi ha impiegato due anni
twitter nove mesi
e indovinate quanto tempo abbiamo
impiegato per diffondere giochi online
come per esempio nel 2016 pokémon go 19
giorni
ed ecco qui la prima risposta abbiamo il
telefono che è entrato dapprima nel 1877
nonostante 75 anni nelle nostre attività
produttive i pokemon go con la realtà
virtuale aumentata che vantaggio hanno
portato invece nel nelle nostre attività
il rischio di qualche incidente a me è
capitato mentre andava al lavoro perché
la macchina ha frenato e il ritardo di
qualche dipendente che mentre veniva
loro si è soffermato acea prendere
qualche pokémon per strada quindi il non
corretto utilizzo delle tecnologie ci
sta rendendo improduttivi
negli ultimi 50 anni come abbiamo
risolto il problema del dell'aumento
delle richieste da parte dei consumatori
mantenendo alta la competitività abbia
preso le nostre aziende
le abbiamo delle utilizzate nei paesi
più poveri del mondo abbia aumentato le
loro dimensioni
abbiamo settorializzato i processi
generando sfruttamento povertà e
ricchezza di pochi
le tre rivoluzioni citate prima hanno
portato crescita perché l'innovazione è
stata introdotta all'interno dei
processi produttivi
dal 2010 si parla come unica soluzione
alla crisi economica in cui siamo
immersi
l'industria 4.0 perché quel modello che
vi ho mostrato prima non funziona più
indusse 4.0 prevede specifiche e
determinata e tecnologia big data realtà
aumentata virtuale cloud sono tante ma
le abbiamo già non dobbiamo svilupparle
indusse 4.0 prevede di prendere queste
tecnologie introdurle all'interno dei
nostri processi produttivi delle aziende
creando interazione tra digitale e
fisico
si vuole rendere le nostre imprese un po
più intelligente e connesse tra loro a
ogni livello interno ed esterno ma
ricordiamo con adeguate conoscenze e
competenze e con innovazione di massa e
continua innovazione di massa e continua
che bollina induci 4.0 non prevede isole
innovative e vi racconto la mia storia
io sono sono dapprima sono un ingegnere
laureata e specializzata in sistemi
informativi territoriali da subito dopo
la mia laurea ho iniziato a lavorare
come libero professionista e poi il
risultato è che poteva avere lo studio
più 4.0 d'italia
ma se mi interlocutori non parlava
stessa lingua ogni mio sforzo economico
ravano e intellettuale poteva per il
software migliori e migliori tecnologie
per consegnare fare quattro progetti in
un pomeriggio ma non potevo consegnarli
al cliente perché ero in attesa delle
necessarie autorizzazioni
io libero professionista lavoro prova a
sfruttare quella che la mia passione la
mia specializzazione gis geographic
information system informatizzare
cartografie catasto piani regolatori
tutto ciò che di carta società e
centralizzare questi sistemi lavoro per
siano in maniera continuativa per tanti
enti tra cui la mia regione a regione
sicilia e immaginate il vantaggio
competitivo per la nostra regione se
l'ente pubblico non avesse bloccato in
preda alla crisi post 2008 proprio il
settore digitale compreso il mio si
poteva scatenare una rivoluzione per
tutti e invece tutto si è fermato
rendendo vano ogni sforzo economico
intellettuale fatto fino ad allora è
bene un po delusa la diffusione di varie
tecnologie di industry 4.0 nel 2010 mi
convincono a esplorare nuovi modelli di
business
soft per esempio sta per software as a
service dove è possibile immettere
fornire software in rete invece che
vendere pacchetti da installare nei
propri sistemi
questo mi convince a prendere un
progetto che va nel cassetto insieme a
mio fratello e portarlo online e tra me
e il cliente sembrava che non ci fossero
più barriera perché c'era internet e
basta ma mi rendo conto anche nel 2013
dopo tanti successi nazionali
internazionali e quindi dopo aver
ricevuto il finanziamento del venture
capital da 400mila euro che ci permette
un inversione del mercato veloce che tra
noi e il cliente c'era qualcosa di molto
grande e il mercato globale
ed ecco le difficili logiche del mercato
globale che mi sento di nuovo un isola
innovativa perché mi scontro con delle
evoluzioni del mio paese che mi rendono
sempre più isola del 17 il mio successo
più grande
mia figlia è nella mia vita è una gioia
infinita ma nel mio mondo del lavoro
nella mia professione mi sento ancora di
nuovo un'isola ancora più isola perché
un'involuzione per farvi capire meglio
cosa intendo
basti pensare che in italia lo smart
working è ancora una chimera
la possibilità di lavorare da casa è
ancora impossibile in italia per enti
aziende professionisti cittadini soci
partner tutti questo mi convince a
abbandonare la mia start up non sono più
presidente e godermi la mia tanto
dedidata maternità per non rallentare
questa creatura che avevo la startup che
avevo creato e che ora già giustamente
grandi difficoltà in questo mercato
nel 2018 leggo del piano nazionale
impresa 4.0 ovvero della possibilità di
scatenare all'interno del di tutta
italia
all'interno delle camere di commercio
delle piccoli dei punti impresa digitale
per scatenare appunto insieme alle
imprese questa quarta rivoluzione
industriale in tutto il territorio
italiano
mi candido partecipa alle selezioni e il
risultato è che da novembre 2018 mi
trovo a fianco di unioncamere infocamere
camei commercio sudest sicilia quindi la
camera del mio territorio catania
siracusa ragusa per affrontare questa
quarta rivoluzione industriale di tali
insieme alle imprese e quindi sono
finalmente dentro l'ente pubblico che
dialoga continuamente con le imprese
unico vero polmone economico italiano e
grandi armi forse le uniche per
contrastare questa profonda crisi ma
ricordiamo solo se convertite
all'industrie 4.0 con adeguate
conoscenze e competenze e con
un'innovazione continua e di massa
non prevediamo isole innovativa c'è
ancora un abbiamo quattro punti a nostri
quattro strumenti a nostra disposizione
i primi due prevedono contributi
economici perché le aziende segnalano
sempre grandi problemi per delle risorse
economiche da reperire figure e
tecnologia
il secondo punto è anche nel reperire le
figure in termini di attrattività perché
spesso le figure altamente qualificata
preferisco andare a lavorare per le
grandi aziende non le piccole gli altri
due punti prevedono invece mappatura
digitale del livello di maturità
digitale dell'impresa è l'altro punto
importantissimo è la formazione alle
imprese
questi ultimi due punti invece vogliono
innescare dentro l'impresa e gli
imprenditori la voglia di esplorare
capire e comprendere che il mestiere di
innovare non potrà per sempre essere
delegato esternamente
e che diventerà sempre più parte del
core business aziendale capire come
queste aziende si vedranno tra dieci
anni comprendere che ogni devono devo
analizzare ogni come ogni tecnologia
cambierà il proprio modo di lavorare il
proprio modello di business
allo stato attuale sono meno del 14 per
cento le imprese che hanno adottato
tecnologia di industry 4.0 che sono
riuscite quindi innescare questo
processo è quindi quasi 87 per cento non
sono riuscite assolutamente ad attivare
questo questo questo processo
ma il dato più eclatante è che meno le
piccole quelle con meno di 25 persone
sono le aziende che non hanno ancora
neanche non si sono neanche affacciati a
guardare la quarta rivoluzione
industriale
qui sono tagliate fuori al momento
questo è un grande problema perché se
non portiamo queste aziende a competere
nel mondo il problema che presto avremo
sarà ancora più grande
ma quanto contano queste micro piccole e
medie imprese in italia tanto tantissimo
soprattutto il meridione e soprattutto
in sicilia dove vediamo che danno un
contributo alla produzione regionale
pari all 83 per cento e spesso vicino
anche all 85 questo questo dato insieme
ha messo insieme a quante al campione è
del 6 per cento delle micro aziende quel
piccolo campione che quindi aziende
inferiore ai dieci addetti che sono
riusciti a trasformarsi e che dimostrano
che il loro fatturato è cresciuto e gli
occupati sono cresciuti e quindi che il
fattore dimensionale l'essere piccole
non è più così così importante che
dimostra soprattutto come già economie
globali stiamo passando economie locali
ci fa capire che se noi consideriamo per
la regione sicilia che ha un contributo
ripetiamo dell 83 per cento rispetto al
contributo nel medio nazionale del 57
per cento all conte
regionale ci fa capire come questa si
può trasformare in una grande
opportunità per la nostra regione
io vi ho raccontato oggi i 360 gradi
perché industry 4.0 è un'opportunità se
gestite a 360 gradi ma soprattutto
voglio dimostrare che la mia opinione
vale 2 centesimi ma la mia opinione che
le imprese siciliane da spettatori
possono diventare protagonista della
quarta rivoluzione industriale
[Applauso]
[Musica]